alan bueno se trata de 160 ciudades
están supuestamente en alerta roja y 208
ciudades que están en alerta naranja el
gobierno ha decidido tomar estas medidas
debido al alza de los números de muertes
pero también de casos positivos hasta
llegar a estados alarmantes entonces lo
que ha hecho es permitir que muchas
empresas sigan trabajando pero ha
cerrado todos los comercios no
esenciales y ha pedido a la población
que se encierre a partir de las 9 de la
noche hasta las 4 de la mañana y ha
pedido a todas estas autoridades
milicias ejército que ayude a controlar
la situación pues ha dicho que la
economía del país no puede soportar más
que el cob y siga avanzando pero
especialmente aquellos que trabajan en
el los sistemas de salud en iran
catalinas habla de una tercera ola de la
pandemia porque se deciden tomar estas
medidas
ahora también se habla de otras cifras
distintas a las oficiales
de hecho hay muchas versiones en un país
como irán pero del ministerio incluso en
salud se ha hablado de que la cifra
puede ser dos veces mayores así que si
lo ponemos en este en este contexto
serían mil muertes más o menos durante
el día y lo que ha hecho irán también es
aumentar el número de pruebas que está
haciendo antes no hacía más de 50.000 ha
aumentado a 100.000 muchas de ellas
pruebas rápidas que empezará a hacer
desde hoy para así controlar más rápido
la pandemia porque hacerlo ahora porque
la situación es mucho más dramática que
antes pero también hay una presión
política frente al gobierno para hacerlo
porque el gobierno ha sido bastante
criticado por su labor durante estos
meses y ya la oposición empieza a
llamarlo al parlamento y aquí estamos en
vísperas de elecciones así que están
tratando de tomar medidas para que ésta
a la moderada que representa a rohan y
tenga alguna oportunidad en las
elecciones del próximo junio